before the show we asked some of our  audience members what they would do with  the 1.5 billion if they won the  Powerball some of their answers are  pretty interesting check it out for  example this guy said he would self  publish all 17 volumes of my Indiana  Jones fan fiction finally fund my idea  for an app that's just like uber except  they just come to your house and punch  you in the mouth check this one out and  move into Downton Abbey this one travel  to Kyoto Japan and train with master  Tokugawa in the deadly waves of the  samurai or by one of those curved TVs  look at this one  purchase daniel radcliffe all right this  one launched my new company cool Jesus  Oxfordshire  [Applause]  and finally look at this one create some  kind of fancy gizmo to get all those  goddamn kids off of it hey thanks for  watching please subscribe to my youtube  channel so they will stop making me  shoot these videos